you weren't serious about uh
uh playing joe exotic were you you were
kidding around do you want to play joe
exotic
i did interview some of those people for
the show just for fun this is a
sort of a lark oh yeah and it was it was
fun once i talked to him yeah
they uh they all watched joe dirt and so
they said they will talk to joe dirk
honestly and they were all funny i
couldn't watch them i mean the first
time you see it you're just like
sort of laughing because the characters
are so crazy after a while you start to
figure out what's really going on and
you're like uh
it gets a little too rough you know and
and then at the cd
back stories and so they'll probably
make a movie or a show about it but
to make a comedy i was thinking of how i
would even do it it's sort of a hat on a
hat which is that
i think that comedy term which means
it's already funny how am i going to
make that
funny er than it is because it's already
like they're playing it like an snl
sketch like carol baskin's crazy and he
dresses crazy and funny haircuts and
so i don't know kate mckinnon i heard is
doing something with carol baskin and
she's very good
so maybe she'll think about take the
dramatic way to do it or some other way
and a different angle to come in on it
to make it worth doing
why would you make a movie of that
anyway let's face it they already made a
movie of it's a documentary that
everybody loved it's enough
i think it just was popular that people
said they got to do something and then i
kind of look like this little squid
so of course everyone's like david spade
should play this gross guy i'm like
thanks
like that's my big end